de notre invité morgane dalle on écoute
bonsoir morgan dalle merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france vous avez
manifesté aujourd'hui aux côtés des
gilet jaune vos revendications sont les
mêmes que celles de ses gilet jaune
qu'on connaît maintenant depuis deux ans
non non non nous revendications ne sont
pas les mêmes parce que nous à l'heure
actuelle on nous n'avons plus la
possibilité de travailler c'est à dire
que nous ne pouvons plus clair trappe à
paris il est peu salariés nous n'avons
plus non plus de chiffres d'affaires à
l'heure actuelle nos cas sont en train
de se vider on a déjà 80 deux
entreprises qui ont déposé le bilan et
300 qui risque de le déposer
fin décembre à ce rythme là au mois de
mars avril 25 à 40 mille emplois seront
sur le carreau ce que vous réclamez
concrètement et à vous avez vous eu des
aides de la part du gouvernement jusqu'à
présent alors on a eu les aides comme
toutes les entreprises ont pu les avoir
bon faut pas oublier quand même que le
système français était le plus généreux
en terme d' aide par rapport au reste de
l'europe
mais il faut remarquer que pour les
discothèques
il n'y a pas eu de mesures spéciales
c'est à dire qu on a on est fermé et on
n'a pas d'être supplémentaires alors que
tous les commerçants ont pu rouvrir les
entreprises ont pu remplir leurs caisses
ont pu payer leurs salariés à 100 car
nous les rangs on ne les paye pas à 100
on les paye à 85%
et en plus de ça on a encore en charge
une partie de leur salaire
donc nous ce qu'on aimerait c'est
pouvoir rencontrer rapidement monsieur
grise et on attend de son retour pour
négocier davantage dead est une
ouverture de nos établissements
on veut également pouvoir participer à
l'économie comme tous les commerçants
c'est à dire qu on est on est pas on
veut être aussi bien lotis que les
autres commerçants
on veut pouvoir rouvrir nos discothèques
en aménageant nos pistes de danse pour
éviter la diffusion du coït bien entendu
aménagé l'épisode ans donc avec des
carrés vip séparer de 2 à 3 mètres par
an on sépare et donc les groupes de dix
de manière à pouvoir et
allemand apporter notre pierre à
l'édifice dans cette dans cette lutte
qu'on peut coville un contexte
particulier puisque à paris notamment le
port du masque est obligatoire partout
comment faire en discothèque selon vous
c'est très simple comme on le fait au
cinéma c'est à dire que on oblige le
masque on prévoit du gel hydroalcoolique
nous qu'on a pas on est prévue en test
de température à l'entrée et
l'application stop coville qui est très
plus utilisé nous on voulait pouvoir
l'utiliser
la mettre en place de manière à ce que
si les ricains contact on puisse
prévenir tous nos clients et identifier
les personnes qui ont été en contact
avec les cas et comment comment rouvrir
on a vu les restaurateurs qui ont
bénéficié des espaces supplémentaires
sur sur l'espace public pour pouvoir
mettre leurs tables est ce que les
discothèques ne pourrait pas aussi avoir
des lieux en plein air bon je pense pas
je pense pas qu'on en aura je pense pas
qu'on nous l'acceptera après pourquoi
pas nous sommes ouverts à tous et on
aimerait bien également pouvoir pouvoir
faire du chiffre d'affaires non déjà
pouvoir ouvrir en mode dégradé ce serait
une très grosse avance et surtout qu'il
faut pas oublier une chose c'est qu'on
va rentrer dans l'hiver nos jeunes vont
faire la fête dans des appartements dans
des bars bondés comme on l'a comme on
peut le voir sur paris à 200 300
personnes sans masque sans gestes
barrières sans sécurité
alors que nos jeunes dans nos
établissements sont en sécurité on sait
faire on a lutté contre le sida
on a lutté également contacter paul est
mis au volant et comptait cigarettes
dans les établissements faisons-nous
confiance de toute façon comme je les
dis les jeunes vont faire la fête on l'a
vu cet été
cet été c'était en extérieur il y a eu
énormément de fête sauvage
là cet hiver ce sera en intérieur il
faut pouvoir maîtriser tout cela faisait
conques faisons confiance aux
professionnels de la nuit une limitation
d'entrée par exemple vous pouvez
garantir ça il faudra en discuter avec
avec les autres membres du collectif cas
actuellement on n'a pas encore eu de
portes ouvertes
mais pourquoi pas si on est aidé
financièrement ouvrir en mode dégradé
ça ne nous dérange pas mais qu'on soit
aidée financièrement
parce que pour l'instant entre ce qui
nous a été promis et ce qui tombe dans
nos caisses
il ya un fossé c'est à dire que moi pour
ma part on a j'ai pas eu encore d'être
j'ai eu trois fois 1500 euros depuis le
mois de mars et je n'ai pas eu de
salaire ont tenu aujourd'hui morgan vous
vous sentez gilet jaune profondément ou
pas non je me sens pas les jeunes je me
sens citoyen je me sens un citoyen qui
n'a plus un quine qui ne peut plus
travailler
c'est à dire que à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
on ne peut plus travailler c'est grave
il faut il faut se remettre au travail
pour remettre les discothèques au
travail faut les laisser pouvoir faire
tourner l'économie
laissez-nous collecter de la tva laissez
nous payer nos salariés
c'est ce qu'on demande pouvoir
travailler comme tous les français
merci morgan dalle d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur rt france